this video is sponsored by skillshare
you ever just sit somewhere staring
blankly to the air and go
i wish i was smarter if only there was
some
easy to use online way to learn
well cheer up mr bandit skillshare is
here to help
all right introducing the completely
online hassle-free learning community
that brings its users
literally thousands of inspirational
classes for people looking to get more
creative
i've been using it personally and have
really been enjoying the class called
plants at home
uplift your spirit and your space from
christopher griffin as i do lots of my
work at home these days
i even started growing some bonsai trees
for myself for this very purpose
which i definitely planted correctly and
are absolutely going to sprout any day
now
please sprout and since the good people
of skillshare are really only interested
in healthy
fun ways to learn stuff there aren't any
ads in videos or on pages and they
update their library with new classes
all the time
so you could be learning how to create
landscapes or animate in 3d or 2d or
write
songs or even learn to play the guitar
ad free for under 10 bucks a month
so no matter what 2021 brings you can
create something meaningful out of
skillshare's creative library because
after all time is what we make of it so
if any of this sounds even remotely
interesting to you
good news is that the first 1000 of my
subscribers to click the link in the
description below will get a
free trial of the premium membership so
you can explore that creativity and now
on to the video
bandits are pretty cool and if you don't
agree with me i'm deeply offended
but did you know that there was actually
a bandit in breath of the wild
no you didn't see them anywhere in game
which must mean they were a pretty good
bandit actually
but the very astute fans will recall
hearing the name
misco the great bandit in rumors across
the land of hyrule and also the side
quest
called misco the great bandit this misco
character was also the author of the ex
journal that serves to reveal the
locations of some very key artifacts
from across the zelda franchise
but the journal doesn't actually matter
to the game's canon actually
it kind of does sorry to scare you
bandit but did you
forget that we are doing these videos
together ah no
of course i didn't forget
well i'm sure you remember that the
bandit's actions absolutely do
matter to the game's canon and that is
exactly what we're talking about in my
video
ah yes of course well as i was saying
misco is also the author of the ex
journal that leads to items which we'll
actually be covering over in the monster
maze video
so be sure to check it out after
watching here the link to it will be in
the description below and in a card at
the end of the video
i want to ask a very interesting
question about the other
great bandit in this video which may
seem kind of silly at first but becomes
pretty convincing the more you think
about the evidence presented
and that question is this what if misco
the great bandit
is still alive take it away mr mays
why thank you like i mentioned
previously we believe that the ex
journal that appears in the game
after you purchase the dlc is actually
canon which we'll go into more detail
over in my video
that being said though if the journal
and its items are truly canonically
present then the odd circumstances
surrounding their appearance must also
be canon
to be clear what i'm talking about is
the fact that the journal seems to
appear out of nowhere upon purchasing
the dlc
like literally there's nothing on this
shelf in the middle of the outpost ruins
before the dlc
and after the dlc is downloaded there's
the journal but this isn't just
something to be noticed by the players
link himself even reacts to its
appearance by questioning whether or not
it was there before
we know it was not of course so this
begs the question
how did it all of a sudden just appear
on this shelf was it
moved here or perhaps placed here by
someone since that is far and away the
most likely scenario then who
placed misco's ex journal here i think
the most likely answer would be misco
themselves personally
yeah it doesn't make much sense for
anyone else to be able to do that but
wouldn't that mean that misco is still
alive today
it would but we're going to delve into
that a bit later in the video
i want to pause on that note and switch
gears real quick to discuss some clues
we can find from the quest
called misco the great bandit which
takes place without the game's dlc
you see link receives this quest by
talking to prison and dominak
two twin brothers at the dueling peaks
stable who are discussing the location
of misco's hidden treasure horde
actually link kind of butts into their
conversation but i mean since when did
he have any
real people skills am i right anyway for
the price of a massive 100 rupees
dominic tells link a riddle that
apparently leads to the hidden location
of misco's treasure horde
which it does indeed do the riddle that
domidak
sells to link goes as follows the little
twin
steps over the little river my cave
rests over that river's source
now i know what you're thinking that is
the easiest
riddle ever i mean the only part about
the riddle that's actually even somewhat
vague is the little twin part
as river and source are both specific
and non-debatable but if you walk like
10 feet out of the stable
you can see the big twin bridge and
right on the other side of it
the little twin bridge and what is
literally the only thing that sits over
a river
a bridge it's literally like 50 meters
away and called
little twin statistically speaking these
kids
would have to have an iq of like 2 to
not be able to solve this extremely easy
riddle now you might be thinking
why am i going over how ridiculous the
riddle was oh
i think i know go for it man because
they weren't actually trying to solve
the riddle but let me back up and point
out one other detail real quick when
domadek tells link where he got the
riddle from
the answer is some ridiculous lineage
where the riddle was apparently passed
to him from a
quote former dog walker of one of
misco's underlings descendants neighbors
then he says it's as a solid lead as any
the funny thing is it
is actually a solid lead because it
literally leads to the exact location of
the treasure
so here we have an extremely simple and
easy to solve riddle being apparently
passed down with 100 accuracy by a
ridiculously vague lineage of different
individuals
quite frankly the only realistically
believable solution to this
ridiculousness would be if dominic and
prison
already knew the answer but why wouldn't
they have just gone and gotten the
treasure themselves if they already knew
where it was
well ladies and gents i present to you
the identities of misco
the great bandit the twins domidak in
prison
precisely think about it the random
lineage dominic mentioned
may be more than just random it might be
the passage of the title
of misco the great bandit because as we
talked about earlier
misco had to have both existed in the
past since that's when they were said to
be robbed from the castle and that can
only happen if the castle was occupied
which it hasn't been for 100 years
but misco also has to still exist today
in order to place the ex journals in the
outpost ruins so what if that lineage
domidak mentions was
actually secretly the identities of
every previous holder of the misco title
each of them protecting the secrets of
misco's treasure
leading from the original bandit all the
way to these twins
that actually makes a ton of sense but
something's still bothering me though
why would the bandits give away their
treasure horde and then their precious
relics in the dlc
well bandit uh i mean masked nintendo
bandit remember how i said that the
misco title passes from one individual
or group of individuals to another what
if they were waiting in the stable to
find
the next worthy individual for someone
to come by and willing to give up a bit
of money for the sake of treasure and
solve their riddle
proving that they have what it takes to
be a true bandit so they could pass
along the title of misco once again
and after they checked and saw that the
riddle was in fact solved they left a
journal that reveals the locations of
the buried stolen relics so that they
would be under the safe keeping of the
next misco
i mean breath of the wild is full of
trials right why couldn't the quest for
misco's treasure and the dlc items be
the trial to find the next great bandit
well my mind is officially blown i mean
it's true that we don't have much
in-game lore about misco but given what
we do have
this seems to be the best solution to
the mystery so you're telling me that
the current identity of
misco the great bandit could be
none other than link himself hey if the
shoe fits
i love it and all this bandit talk is
making my bandit heart happy it makes me
excited to talk about the ex items
which will be happening over on your
channel mr mays speaking of which though
thanks so much for helping out with this
fun little theory
hey man the pleasure was all mine i mean
getting to talk about bandits with
the masked nintendo bandit who could
resist that thank you for having me and
if you want to see more cool zelda stuff
head over to my channel
monster maze and i'll see you there and
thank you guys for watching
please consider dropping a like to get
this video spread around on youtube and
subscribe to the channel so you never
miss out on more fun nintendo content as
always
humongous thanks to my supporters of
which i have a few new faces to announce
please give a big round of applause for
doza 89 and claire j
who have each joined up with the great
bandit uh
mass nintendo bandit that is if you
watching are interested in helping the
next video come to life
or helping me put some food on the table
please feel free to check out that join
button located below any video or
following the links in the description
below for my patreon page
also down there are links to my social
media pages so come follow me if you
want to see updates on my new
akita puppy i know he's so cute that's
all for this one folks so as always i
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day
i look forward to seeing you over on
monster mace's channel peace
[Music]
you